- This is my ASMR video.
- Oh my gosh.
(mellow, jazzy music)
- Today we're gonna be trying
some Japanese drunk snacks.
Ooh, it's in a box.
"Otsumami Set," that's cute.
Also, it says "let's party" on it
which is a directive I
much appreciate getting.
- Woo!
Alright, okay.
You know, I can trust anything
that's in a package like this.
- [Both] Wasabi!
- [Jen] Wow, these'll be good.
- Okay, I'm excited now.
- Yeah, we love wasabi-flavored things.
- What did the A say to B?
- What did it say?
- Was-a-bi.
- What does that mean?
- It's a joke.
- Oh. (laughs dramatically)
- Oooh.
- Is this like crackers?
- You know when you said wasabi flavor
I thought I was gonna be
like I was eating wasabi.
- It tastes kind of like a
Pop Chip with just like a hint
of the wasabi nose-clearing flavor.
- I like that cruch though.
It's a really satisfying
crunch, are you ready for this?
ASMR. (crunches loudly)
- [Steven] Scallop, baby!
(Jen chuckles)
You all, scallops are good.
- So, scallop flavored,
it smells pretty similar
to the wasabi one.
- I feel like I'm eating a bad version
of a crostini with tuna.
- I feel that way too, but I like it.
- Yeah, but you like everything.
- So, let's just take a look at this.
This is called "Gratz," oh "Cratz."
- Crackers.
- I don't know how to read.
Cratz, so I guess they're crackers.
They look like tiny little
Corn Nuts, honestly.
This smells like hot dogs.
- Yeah.
- These smell exactly like hot dogs.
I hope they taste like hot dogs.
And I got a nut?
Okay, let's do it.
Whoa.
- Yo.
- These taste exactly like hot dogs!
- I would buy this every day.
- Okay, this one is
butter and salt flavored.
- I'm gonna love this, I already know.
- Wow, this smells like movie
theater buttered popcorn.
- You know when they serve
you bread before a meal?
- Mm-hmm.
- This is what they should serve.
- Let's try the last one.
These are edamame flavored
and I really like edamame.
- These are cute!
These are like marshmallows.
- These are really cute,
they look like Lucky Charms.
- Whoa.
(Steven makes confused noise)
It tastes like very, very salty edamame.
I like the edamame the best.
The flavor seems a little bit more mild.
[Steven sounds out Japanese word]
That's a doozy.
Japanese drunk snacks seem pretty buttery.
- This is like Outback Steakhouse bread.
Yo, they're really cute faces though.
- [Jen] Yeah, they look really scared.
(both crunching)
No, I don't like that.
It kinda tastes like
wasabi that's gone bad.
- Maybe they're growing
different avocados in Japan.
Maybe we're doing it wrong.
- Maybe avocados are
supposed to taste like that.
In which case...
- Good job?
Oh, wow. (makes silly sound)
So strong!
- Fuck.
- Would you eat this if you were drunk?
- I mean, if I were
drunk I'd eat anything.
(Steven chuckles)
I would probably eat cardboard.
Cheese.
- It.
(both crunching)
- What I like about it is you
can clearly taste the cheddar
and then it's very buttery.
- This is like a slightly
more intense Cheez-It.
- [Steven] Heck yes!
See, this is what I'm talking about.
- [Jen] This is good.
I ate so much black sesame-flavored,
so this I'm actually really excited about.
- Oh yeah.
That's like a drug to me.
- Hit me.
- Here.
- That smells awesome.
(Steven moans)
- That's heavenly.
- Let's eat it.
(both crunching)
Yeah, that's really good.
- It almost has seaweed vibes,
just the mildness of it.
"Gomaaza," you go.
"Maaza."
I want to give somebody this set
just because it looks cool
and it's fun for a party.
- I mean, the thing is if
you were having a party,
this is such a convenient
way to serve snacks.
Just pop this down on the table,
pop it open,
and then everyone can just grab
something on their way out.
And if there's one thing that
drunk people love, it's fun.
- And games.
- Oh yeah.
- Fun and games.
- And toys, this seems
just like a big toy.
- Oh yeah.
- [Jen] Bye, don't tell anyone.
(mellow, jazzy music)
(cup clattering)
- [Steven] Okay. (laughs)
Wanna play beer pong?
- [Jen] Yeah.